[Music]
today is April 20th or 4/20 it's a date
long considered to be national weed day
whose all the stoners in the audience
know that the CBS News poll released
this morning shows the number of
Americans in favor of legalizing
marijuana has reached a new high 61% of
Americans think pot should be legal
that's a five that's a five-point
increase over last year more than half
of all states have legalized medical
marijuana and eight states along with
the District of Columbia allowed
marijuana for recreational purposes
Barry Petersen is at a marijuana
dispensary in Denver with how Colorado
is handling the financial windfall from
the weed sales and the stigma very good
morning to you good morning
well the marijuana plants just in this
room are worth half a million dollars
part of Colorado pot industries 1.3
billion dollars in sales last year and
it turns out that good pot business is
good news for cash-strapped cities and
even college kids a small Denver suburb
of flags and front porches Edgewater is
all-american and oh by the way it has
six pot shops drawing big business from
nearby cities that opted not to allow
marijuana sales this town of 5,300 is
generating 1.4 million dollars in sales
tax revenue from pot that's 20% of its
annual budget money for we're paving 12
miles of streets and the old City Hall
will soon be replaced by a new 10
million dollar complex that will include
the police station and library to be
finished by 2018 how much is that is
gonna be pot money if it's remains
illegal all of it Wow
HJ stuff is city manager does anybody
ever jump up and say it's great to have
all that money but it's kind of Sin City
it's a it's a drug operation that's
paying for all of this I would say
there's probably a few people in town
that feel that way but it's not commonly
discussed
Denver marijuana shop owner Tim Cullen
wanted to give back to the community by
donating $200,000 to a non-profit
several said thanks but no thanks he
believed it was the stigma of pot money
I was shocked
honestly I was shocked it was it was
more difficult than I thought it would
be this is where the Levitt pavilion
will be he took us to a denver park
where the city accepted his donation as
part of a private-public project to
build a pavilion for free concerts does
the day come when you make a donation
like this and nobody pays attention I
mean you could be the pot shop or you
could be the corner grocery maybe maybe
I think so I mean I think we're years
away from that being the case about a
hundred and ten miles south of Denver
public outing is also benefiting from
marijuana taxes the county gets its
sales taxes when marijuana is harvested
and sold to pot shops statewide money
now giving college kids a first in
American history pot funded scholarships
now are you comfortable with the fact
that this is sales tax but it's from
marijuana yeah because it's helping me
continue my education freshman Jenna
calls the DEA's wants to be a teacher
she's getting a thousand dollars a
semester at Colorado State University in
Pueblo
I don't think without this scholarship
I'd be able to continue my education
without taking out loans and worrying
about how I'm going to pay them back and
this coming spring every graduating high
school student in Pueblo County will
qualify for a pot scholarship to be used
at local colleges
those scholarships in the help for the
cities will really be heard if the Trump
administration bans the sale of legal
recreational pot even if it still allows
sales for medical purposes pot advocates
say they'll still buy pot for
recreational use but the cities and
states will get zero sales tax from the
black-market Nora all right Barry thank
you really interesting to hear how
communities are benefiting I think so
too and it's going to higher education
put out bomb one more aspect of a
growing business that's right that's
right